[Music]
imagine that you were a young reporter
you've heard about an environmental
project out on the oregon seacoast which
hosts one of the most extensive sand
dunes in the world
hundreds of miles of sand extending
miles inland
where the winds blowing from the sea
move the dunes so that they threaten
towns and railroads agriculture and
forests
the project is meant to protect all that
is threatened from the moving sand
you learn that since the 1800s people
have planted different varieties of
beech grass to put roots into the sands
to prevent them from spreading the
projects are beginning to bear fruit
with extensive areas of the dunes
becoming stabilized you write a story
about this casting the engineers in
charge of the projects as heroes
protecting civilization from the ravages
of time
you link the spread of the sands to lost
cities of the past and tell of how
entire civilizations have been buried
under the shifting sands
you pitch the story to your agent who
declines it on the grounds that there is
not enough human interest in it
this is not the most auspicious origin
story for one of the greatest works of
science fiction of the 20th century
the young reporter frank herbert the
novel
dune
according to his son brian herbert
frank's visit to florence oregon the
place of the sand dunes was a direct
inspiration for dune
it's too simplistic of course to say
that this was the only inspiration for
this work however the project that
herbert was interested in makes a
compelling link between the science used
in the novel with the real and very
important project of environmental
science
in this lecture we're going to see how
the science of ecology plays a major
role in shaping the plot of dune and its
sequels
and even more specifically how frank
herbert the author anticipated a major
and still controversial theory of
planetary ecology the gaia hypothesis
we will also examine the oregon dunes
stabilization project to see how it
influenced aspects of the first three
novels of the dunes series
and how such projects both real and
fictional
always carry unintended consequences
herbert anticipated some of these in his
novels the real efforts which are still
underway
involve a number of other ones
along the way we will look at dune's
ecological cycle as created by the giant
sand worms
and see how it has similar elements to
daisy world a fictional world invented
for purely scientific purposes
we will also investigate a more perverse
example of a science fiction ecology
david gerold's unfinished war against
the couture series
i'm going to specifically talk about the
novel dune originally published in 1965
and three of its sequels dune messiah
children of dune and god emperor of dune
rather than any of the movies or tv
adaptations this is because none of the
adaptations have the same ecological
focus that the original novel and its
sequels have the novels are also
infinitely richer in plot and settings
than any of the mass media works based
on them
the importance of dune was recognized
immediately
it won both of the two biggest awards in
science fiction the hugo
given by science fiction fans and the
nebula
given by science fiction writers i think
this underscores two things about the
book it is a very enjoyable read
and it has serious intellectual content
it's also impossible to pigeonhole it
into any science fiction genre
it has elements of what is sometimes
called space opera it features
interstellar travel laser weapons force
fields and a huge galactic empire set
thousands of years in the future
however
it also highlights key elements of the
new wave of science fiction burgeoning
in the 1960s with its emphasis on
culture language religion ecology and
real politique
the language is elevated even archaic in
places and the text is sprinkled with
loan words from many languages and
cultures often middle eastern or arabic
the fremen the desert nomads the souk
the marketplace and the quizadzhatarach
the one who shortens the way
the galactic empire's culture is also
deliberately archaic it is vaguely
futile with mysticism and religion
playing an important cultural role there
are also no computers of any kind
because a of a great conflict thousands
of years in the empire's past the
butlerian jihad was a war between humans
and the artificial intelligences they
had created but hey we covered that
topic in the lecture on robots
to simplify an enormously complicated
story dune begins when dukelato atreides
one of the most powerful nobles in the
empire is sent to govern the desert
world of arrakis the dune of the title
arrakis is a hot dry desert world with a
few scattered settlements and an
impoverished population living at the
edge of survival
it is also the only world that produces
melange
also known as spice
a drug that gives its users psychic
powers
shortly after arriving the duke is
betrayed by a trusted servant to his
enemy the baron harkonnen and is killed
but his consort jessica and son paul
escape
they go to live with the fremen militant
bedouin-like nomads living in the deep
deserts
paul becomes a religious figure uniting
the fremen to overturn the empire if
this storyline seems a tad familiar
remember that dune was published 12
years before star
wars one of the fascinations of dune is
how the ecology of arrakis drives the
story the ecology of arrakis is tied to
the life cycle of the sand worms giant
segmented worm-like creatures that swim
through the sands of the deep desert the
mechanics of how they move is never
explained
although incredibly dangerous the fremen
used the sand worms as transport across
the desert
the sand worms are part of an ecological
cycle that produces the spice and also
ties up the water on dune
it is revealed in the third novel
children of dune that the sand worms are
an invasive species introduced from
another world
sand trout immature sand worms insist
the water blocking it deep underground
from reaching the surface of the planet
water combining with their excretions
produces the spice in giant explosions
called spice blows that occurred due to
the chemical reactions that create the
spice
melange is the central product that
allows the empire to function
giving iraqis importance far beyond what
an impoverished desert world would
normally have
for example it is the drug that allows
the spacing guild navigators to guide
starships through hyperspace
it also gives the benedresserat psychic
powers that let them influence the
empire they are a quasi-religious
organization dedicated to the protection
and breeding of the human race and the
power behind the imperial throne
paul realizes that by controlling the
spice he can control the empire
in the climax of the novel he threatens
to destroy all of the spice plunging the
empire into a dark age
one of the most fascinating aspects of
the novel's approach to ecology and
science in general
is its emphasis on holism
the overall philosophy is that one must
understand complicated systems as
systems
that to study the individual parts
without considering their interactions
will it best result in ignorance and at
worst destroy the system under study
consider the words of kinds the imperial
planetologist of arrakis
there is an internally recognized beauty
of motion and balance on any man healthy
planet
you see in this beauty a dynamic
stabilizing effect essential to all life
its aim is simple to maintain and
produce coordinated patterns of greater
and greater diversity
life improves the closed system's
capacity to stain life
this sounds a lot like the gaia
hypothesis of james lovelock and lynn
margulis
except that it was first proposed in
1972
six years after the novel was published
the gaia hypothesis is that one cannot
view the ecology and the climate of
earth as separate entities rather
life on earth regulates its climate on
both small and large scales to maintain
earth's habitability
this was a controversial idea in the
1970s and still remains one detractors
of the idea focus on the fact that
naively
it seems to imply a purpose to evolution
and the development of complicated
ecologies
this has been called mysticism by some
however
others see the philosophy as viewing
earth's ecology as an example of a
feedback system
one in which elements of the system
react against each other to stabilize it
a classic example of a feedback system
is in the temperature regulation of a
house imagine a thermometer in a house
that is hooked up to both a furnace and
an air conditioner if the temperature
gets above 80 degrees fahrenheit the
thermometer sends a signal to the air
conditioner turning it on
until the temperature drops below that
value if the temperature falls below 60
degrees the thermometer sends a signal
to the furnace heating the house
this is a negative feedback loop
we are trying to keep some parameter the
temperature within a range of values if
it strays too far away either too high
or too low
we apply a correction in the opposite
direction that keeps the parameter
within the correct range
in ordinary speech negative feedback is
well negative something that is
unpleasant in control theory however
negative feedback is a key feature that
keeps systems in stability
james lovelock and lynn margulis
proposed that earth's biosphere keeps
earth's surface temperature within the
limits required for life in a similar
manner to how a thermostat keeps the
temperature of a house within acceptable
limits
there is certainly some truth to this
which can be seen from the natural
greenhouse effect greenhouse gases in
the atmosphere related to life on earth
mainly water vapor and carbon dioxide
warm the earth up
without their presence earth would be
too cold for life
detractors of the theory point out that
most of the water vapor in earth's
atmosphere doesn't come from living
organisms
lovelock and his colleague andrew watson
created a simplified theoretical model
of how life can affect the surface
temperature of a planet the daisy world
this theoretical model reads like
science fiction
it is a model of a hypothetical planet
that has two species of daisies on it
one that absorbs more light from the sun
than its surroundings do the other that
absorbs less
these daisies can thrive in a
temperature range from 5 celsius to 30
celsius and they can hypothetically
spread over the entire planet
if there are more dark daisies than
light the planet heats up the
temperature increases if there are more
light ones than dark ones the planet
cools down
what happens is interesting instead of a
runaway daisy effect where one species
takes over and either heats or cools the
planet to extinction
they coexist in ratios that ensure that
the planetary temperature remains within
the acceptable range
what's even more interesting is that the
authors of the paper showed that if
daisy world sun grew either hotter or
cooler
the environment would adapt to the
change if it got cooler comparatively
more of the dark daisies would grow
heating the planet if the sun got hotter
the opposite would happen
one issue with the gaia hypothesis is
that it is concerned mainly with
negative feedback effects however
positive feedback can be important as
well leading to sudden and drastic
changes in ecological systems
positive feedback is the opposite of
negative feedback
instead of cooling the house when the
temperature is too high the thermostat
turns the furnace on leading to the
temperature getting even higher and
higher
one example of a positive feedback loop
is the runaway greenhouse effect in the
atmosphere of venus
venus is very similar to earth in many
ways in terms of size and composition it
is slightly closer to the sun than earth
is however the slight difference in
distance means that the surface of venus
is bathed in about twice as much energy
as earth is from the sun
increasing illumination led to carbon
dioxide being driven from venus's crust
into its atmosphere
this in turn led to more heating as the
greenhouse effect trapped heat near its
surface
this in turn led to more carbon dioxide
being driven into the atmosphere from
the crust leading to more heating until
we have the situation today the surface
temperature is over 800 degrees
fahrenheit the atmosphere 96 carbon
dioxide and surface atmospheric pressure
is the same as the pressure in the deep
ocean
climatologists fear a similar although
much smaller effect on earth as there is
a lot of methane stored in permafrost in
the arctic and in the oceans methane is
a very effective greenhouse gas
man-made global warming could lead to
permafrost melt and the release of ocean
stores of methane further increasing
global warming in a positive feedback
effect
dunes ecology is just about as simple as
daisy worlds in both cases the inventors
of each planet were working to create a
simpler version of an ecology than the
hugely complicated one on earth
this is a typical reaction of scientists
to intractable problems
in physics we call it the spherical cow
solution creates some sort of theory
that has the key features of the real
system but nothing more than that
remember lecture two
in lovelock and watson's case they
created the simple ecology of daisy
world to illustrate how life could adapt
to changing amounts of solar elimination
in herbert's case he created the ecology
of doing it for the background of a
story
he created enough for a rich tapestry to
serve as a backdrop but not so much that
it intruded in the story
part of this tapestry is the interaction
of humanity with its environment the
cultural side of ecology
the fremen are clandestinely trying to
alter the ecology of arrakis to turn it
into a more temperate world with water
flowing on the surface
to do this they have to disrupt the sand
worm life cycle that ties up the free
water of dune
they are engaged in a centuries-long
process to introduce desert scrub
vegetation that will simultaneously stop
the movement of the dunes free up the
water and cool the planet by their shade
the plan is carefully discussed in an
appendix to the novel
as i mentioned before
this idea was based on a program to
stabilize the oregon sand dunes herbert
even has the fremen planting some of the
same beach grasses as were used in the
real program
it seems like a good time to take a more
in-depth look at the real program it
goes back a long way
much farther back than herbert realized
or at least wrote about in the proposal
for his story
the oregon sand dunes represent a major
and unique environmental region of our
country
in preparing for this lecture i
corresponded with dr sally hacker a
professor of ecology at oregon state
university whose area of research is the
ecology of the oregon dunes
she told me that the history of sand
dune stabilization in the western u.s
goes back to the mid-1800s
to quote a 1984 study
whenever moving sand interferes with the
activities of human beings programs of
stabilization are initiated
the process described is essentially
identical to that described by herbert
and dune to quote further
the first step is always the planting of
european beech grass
this is the only species of beech grass
that can survive in a wide enough array
of sandy environments however
secondary plantings of other species are
needed because beach grasses don't grow
well when sand deposition stops
compare this to the words of frank
herbert who describes the planting of
beech grasses to initially stabilize the
dunes
when barrier dunes reached sufficient
height the windward faces were planted
with tougher sword grasses
now the fremen came in with deeper
plantings after this they turned then to
the necessary animal life
the fremen are clearly following the
oregon plan
introduce tough beach grasses and follow
with other plantings when the
environment becomes less hostile
getting back to those oregon beach
grasses man's struggle against nature
for control of the dunes isn't an
unmitigated success story
few such stories are
the problem with planting european beach
crests along the north american coast is
that european beach grass is well
european
non-native
invasive
the beech grasses drive out native flora
for hundreds of miles along the coast
and have wiped out habitats for various
animals including the oregon silver spot
butterfly and the western snowy plover
the butterfly would have gone extinct in
the 1990s if people hadn't made vigorous
efforts to start recovery programs
the history of ecology is full of
stories like this involving the laws of
unintended consequences science fiction
writers are familiar with this of course
in the dune series one side effect of
the fulfillment of the greening of
arrakis
is the sudden and drastic reduction of
spice production
causing an economic crash of the
galactic economy this issue is explored
in the later books
and is similar in some ways to the
temporary effects the arab oil embargo
had on the u.s economy in 1973
eight years after the book was published
on a side note the use of weather
satellites is mentioned as almost a
throwaway line in the book this is
interesting because the use of
satellites to monitor earth's weather
was pretty new when doom was first
published i think that herbert was one
of the first science fiction authors to
use the idea of weather satellites in
science fiction nowadays such satellites
are commonplace but back then they
emphasized the otherworldly feel of the
novel in a time when images of the earth
from space were rare and novel
of course
dune isn't the only example of ecology
and science fiction
perhaps the alien ecology that has been
most extensively worked out
is the katorin ecology in the war
against the katura series by david
gerold
this is a story of alien invasion but
not by little green men and flying
saucers instead it is the invasion of
earth by an alien ecology in a manner
similar to how invasive species take
over new environments
the premise of the book is that sometime
in the near future plagues wipe out a
large fraction of humanity
following this never before seen flora
and fauna begin to appear all over the
earth invading and taking over wherever
they appear
humanity fights back but in the four
books published as of early 2020 it is a
losing battle
the books are narrated from the first
person viewpoint of jim mccarthy a
reluctant conscript in the u.s army who
has a talent for surviving
there are two absolutely terrifying
aspects to the series
first of all how bloodthirsty all of the
couture and ecology seems to be
the top of the katorin food chains seem
to be worms gastropods huge worm-like
beings with big round mouths filled with
sharp teeth that eat everything in their
path and are almost impossible to kill
however
many other equally disturbing creatures
have been described from blood-thirsty
swarms of mosquito-like insectoids that
can drain a person dry to huge
enterprise fish larger than an aircraft
carrier living in the deep oceans
the other terrifying aspect is that
whatever is controlling the invasion has
yet to be identified
many characters in the novels speculate
that the real nasties the tops of the
katorin food chain the true invaders
have yet to reveal themselves
others have speculated that in a weird
provision of the gaia hypothesis
the entire katarin ecology is the
invader
that is it functions as a perhaps
self-aware super organism in a manner
similar to how ant colonies operate
it is also possible that the aliens are
couture forming earth in a manner
similar to the gaia hypothesis by
changing earth's average temperature in
a manner very similar to how daisy world
operates
since the katarin ecology is mainly
colored red
the spread of it over the earth changes
earth's albedo the amount of light that
earth on average absorbs from the sun
which in turn will change earth's
overall temperature
making it less suited for terrestrial
life and more for katarin all of this is
speculation right now
the most recent book in the series a
season for slaughter was published in
1993.
david gerold has teased publication
dates for books five through seven in
the series but the dates keep moving
forward so we may never know the answer
to these questions
of course
humans are doing a very good job of
transforming earth into an alien planet
by ourselves
i touched on global warming earlier
there is now a lot of science fiction
that deals with the consequences of what
we are doing to our planet including the
hunger games where large segments of the
us coastline are underwater from rising
sea levels and 40 signs of rain by kim
stanley robinson a five minutes into the
future novel involving political and
scientific responses to mega-disasters
triggered by global warming
the great courses has a lecture series
specifically on global warming earth's
changing climate so i am only going to
touch on a few points here
first of all
global warming is caused by the
anthropogenic greenhouse effect let's
unpack those words starting with the
greenhouse effect
the greenhouse effect is the warming of
the surface of the earth by certain
gases in the atmosphere it is caused by
the fact that some gases like water
vapor carbon dioxide and methane are
transparent to visible light which is
emitted by the sun and warms the earth
but block infrared light which is
emitted by the earth
this means that these gases in the
atmosphere act as a blanket
trapping heat and warming the surface of
the planet
secondly
anthropogenic
anthropogenic means human made
there is a natural greenhouse effect
which is a good thing if it didn't exist
earth would probably be too cold to
sustain life as i mentioned before one
aspect of the gaia theory is that life
controls earth's thermostat many of
these gases are generated or taken up by
living organisms
since the industrial revolution
greenhouse gases emitted due to our
technology have increased the
temperature of the earth by about one
degree celsius so far and are on track
to increase it by another two by the end
of this century
third
scientifically this theory is not
controversial well over 95 percent of
all climatologists
except that this is real
and there is an enormous body of
evidence from the retreating arctic ice
to the migration of species into cooler
latitudes that support it
the theory was first proposed in 1909
by svantarinius a nobel laureate in
chemistry
finally
it is pretty difficult to predict how
much the earth's temperature will change
but not impossible
the reason for this is what i discussed
earlier earth's climate is a system
composed of many parts including earth's
biosphere
changes wrought by humanity increases in
greenhouse gas levels deforestation
changes the weather patterns created by
cities all of these go into climate
models at least indirectly
the system has both negative and
positive feedbacks galore so it becomes
difficult to predict what happens when
you change a single variable it is
holistic in that sense for example
heating increases the amount of water
vapor in the air if it stays in the
atmosphere as vapor it further increases
global warming because water vapor is an
effective greenhouse gas
if it condenses into clouds it might
offset the temperature increase by
blocking sunlight which does it do
only detailed calculations can tell and
there are a hundred other variables to
consider
however
as computers get better the models get
better
and we now see that all of the models
predict more or less the same thing
which more or less they've been
predicting all along if we go on the
same way we're going now the temperature
is going to increase significantly with
disastrous consequences for humanity
not potentially disastrous consequences
mind you
disastrous ones
these probably include the increasing
strength and frequency of hurricanes and
other severe weather
the drought in california and other
places in the world worsening
many species becoming extinct because of
habitat loss danger to agriculture
it's actually hard to overestimate how
bad it could be
i don't want to end this lecture on a
down note
so let's conclude with this hopeful
quote from dune illustrating again how
frank herbert's poetic vision enriched
the scientific background of his writing
life
all life
is in the service of life
necessary nutrients are made available
to life by life in greater and greater
richness as the diversity of life
increases
the entire landscape comes alive filled
with relationships and relationships
within relationships
what a wonderful way to envision an
ecosystem
[Music]
you